hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream sehr schön dass ihr bei uns seid
vor 286 Tagen über viel Russland die
Ukraine und Russland will diesen Krieg
dieses Leid und das Blut vergießen
weiterführen könnte ich zumindest
Wladimir Putin heute an
Stuttgart
was den langen Prozess angeht die Ziele
der spezialoperation zu erreichen
natürlich das kann ein langer Prozess
sein sie haben die Einnahme neuer
Gebiete erwähnt das ist ein bedeutsames
Ziel für Russland ist das schließlich
eine ernste Angelegenheit
so jetzt wissen wir dass der Fokus auf
das aktuelle Kriegsgeschehen vor allem
ja auch auf den Kämpfen in der Luft
gelegen hat die russischen
Drohnenangriffe der vergangenen Wochen
die immer wieder zivile Infrastruktur
der ukrainischen Städte getroffen hat
aber gestern dann eben auch die Meldung
über den erfolgreichen Luftangriff der
Ukraine dann ausführlichen Stream dazu
den findet ihr auch bei uns bei ZDF
heute könnt ihr noch gerne reinschauen
bei Youtube oder in der Mediathek wir
wollen aber heute auf die Situation am
Boden schauen und uns darauf
konzentrieren denn der Winter der ist da
die Tage sind kürzer die Nächte länger
und es ist kalt
wie beeinflusst der Krieg der Winter den
Krieg bringt er womöglich schon eine
Entscheidung das ist die Frage heute die
uns beschäftigt in Sachen Logistik in
Sachen Moral in Sachen Vorteile und
diese Punkte die werden wir ausführlich
analysieren heute ganz ausgeruht und
sachlich mit Oberst in Generalstab
Andreas Schreiber vom German Institut
für defence and the City studies das ist
ein Think Tank der Bundeswehr
schön guten Abend da haben wir sie auch
schon Herr Schreiber vielen Dank dass
Sie heute ihre Kompetenz und ihre
Expertise hier bei ZDF heute live mit
uns teilen guten Abend hoch
bevor wir sprechen natürlich wie immer
der Hinweis an euch was beschäftigen
euch für Fragen für Themen zu dieser
Thematik von uns heute schreibt uns das
gerne in die Chats oder in die
Kommentare oder Mail kennt ihr auch ZDF
heute-live@zedf.de und bevor wir
erschreiber weitersprechen ein kurzer
Überblick von Keilriemen über das was
bisher in diesem Krieg passiert ist
Jubel in herson nach monatelangen
erbitterten Kämpfen haben ukrainische
Truppen am 11 November die Stadt am
Nitro zurückerobert die russische Armee
hat sich auf das östliche Flussufer
zurückgezogen
seitdem kaum Gebietsgewinne und Verluste
auf beiden Seiten die Kämpfe sind
trotzdem nicht weniger schwer russische
Armee und Wagner Truppen versuchen mit
allen Mitteln die Stadt bachmut im Don
das einzunehmen auch um Orte wie auf die
gar und nach Rinka wird er bitter
gekämpft Regen und Schlamm verhinderten
zuletzt aber neue größere offensiven auf
ukrainischer Seite kommen vom Westen
gelieferte Fahrzeuge im aufgeweichten
Gelände kaum voran ändert sich das nun
denn der Winter ist da und im Osten
werden die Temperaturen auf bis zu -20°
fallen bringt der Winter also neue
Entscheidungen im Kampf um die Ukraine
das ist auch die erste Frage an Sie was
denken sie darüber
ja wir werden auf jeden Fall jetzt mit
dem einsetzenden Winter eine andere Art
der Operationsführung sehen als wir sie
in den letzten fast 10 Monaten des
Krieges gesehen haben
wann das tatsächlich sich manifestiert
hängt vom Einsetzen der Dauerfrost
Periode ab
wir haben aktuell Temperaturen gerade im
Bereich des Nordens der Front von bis zu
-5 Grad das wird sich allerdings wohl in
den nächsten Tagen noch mal ändern es
wird wieder etwas wärmer werden das
heißt der Schlamm wird zurückkehren bzw
nicht aufhören aber irgendwann wird der
Winter da sein und spätestens wenn die
wenn der Dauerfrost da ist wird sich die
Qualität verändern das heißt das was
eben dargestellt worden ist nämlich die
wegelosigkeit
der Schlamm die Probleme mit Fahrzeugen
die vor allen Dingen die radgetriebenen
Fahrzeuge der Logistik betreffen all das
wird sich dann ändern
und dann werden wir auf beiden Seiten
Versuche sehen das Beste daraus zu
machen sie sprechen Temperaturen und
auch frostentwicklung an den
unterschiedlichen Regionen die natürlich
auch das Kriegsgeschehen beeinflussen
können wir zusammen drauf schauen wie da
so die aktuellen Prognosen sind das ist
glaube ich haben wir jetzt gleich die
erste Karte vorliegen da ist sie die
frostentwicklung haben sie gerade
angesprochen was sehen wir anhand dieser
Zahlen und Daten und dann anhand auch
ihre Informationen wie das das
Kriegsgeschehen verändert wird ja auf
dieser Karte die vom
geoinformationsdienst der Bundeswehr
bereitgestellt worden ist sehen wir auf
der einen Seite das Eintreten der
Frostperiode nämlich dass der Frost im
Grunde genommen von Norden kommt und je
weiter das dann runtergeht zum Meer und
zur Schwarzmeerküste wird es dann
weniger
das wird dann eben entsprechend auch die
Operationsführung beeinflussen und
darüber hinaus sehen Sie hier
dargestellt vier Bewegungsachsen
bewegungskorridore die sich aus dem
Gelände ergeben und das Gelände ist bei
der landkriegsführung immer einer der
wesentlichen Treiber der Operation gegen
das Gelände kann man keinen Krieg führen
nur mit dem Gelände und wenn man es doch
versucht wird man scheitern
sie haben auch schon angesprochen dass
das eben auch auf die Regionen und auf
dem militärische Situation in den
verschiedenen Orten an der Front
Auswirkungen haben wird hier haben wir
auch noch mal den generellen Überblick
über die aktuelle Situation und was auch
schon durchgeklungen ist bei ihnen ist
das Thema Korridore hier haben wir auch
einen Überblick über die Korridore die
sie thematisieren vielleicht nehmen Sie
uns mit was ist damit genau gemeint und
welche sehen wir da aktuell ja wir sehen
jetzt hier einmal abgetragen den
aktuellen Frontverlauf grob dargestellt
und daraus ergeben sich im Grunde
genommen wesentliche Korridore für die
mögliche Fortsetzung der Operation
das sind im Grunde genommen vier
Korridore die sich aus der Boden
Beschaffenheit aus der Anwesenheit von
Flüssen sehen Gewässern Einschnitten
ergeben und die natürlich Ausfluss oder
Einfluss auf die künftige
Operationsführung haben sowohl auf
ukrainischer wie auch auf russischer
Seite und wir können das mal von Süden
nach Norden durchgehen dass wir wenn wir
mal im Süden beginnen das heißt das ist
der Frontabschnitt zwischen saporicia
der runter geht bis zum Asowschen Meer
wo wir im Prinzip in einer Tiefe von 80
Kilometern in etwa wie hier auf dem Fall
dargestellt vor allen Dingen
steppenartiges Gelände haben mit Flüssen
entlang der Bewegungsrichtung das heißt
dieses Gelände ist grundsätzlich günstig
für mechanisierte Operationsführung und
es ist von den aktuellen
Wetterverhältnissen von diesen vor allem
von dieser extrem Schlammperiode eher
weniger betroffen als die anderen Front
Abschnitte es ist für die Ukraine hier
vergleichsweise einfach eine
mechanisierte Operation in die Tiefe zu
führen und diese Fähigkeit die Operation
in die Tiefe zu führen hängt den erster
Linie davon ab natürlich erstens wie
stark Gegner dort aber vor allen Dingen
wie kann diese Operation in eine Tiefe
von immer in 80 km das ist sehr viel
durchgeführt werden vielleicht ganz kurz
bevor wir uns das weiter anschauen Herr
Schreiber bleiben wir dabei was
prognostizieren sie da was könnte da in
den Wintermonaten passieren in Sachen
Offensive weiter vordringen
ja also wenn man sich gerade in den
sozialen Medien sowohl die Kommentare
der russischen als auch der ukrainischen
mil-blogger und anderer Kommentatoren
anschaut dann ist hier gerade auf
russischer Seite eine massive
Befürchtung zu sehen dass dieses für den
mechanisierten Angriff günstige Gelände
demnächst auch genutzt werden kann das
heißt gerade in der russischen
müllblocker Community liest man sehr
viel das ukrainische Kräfte also Kräfte
auf ukrainischer Seite der Fronten
massiert werden inwieweit das
tatsächlich der Fall ist kann ich jetzt
nicht im Einzelnen nachvollziehen aber
die Gelände Verhältnisse sind natürlich
günstig und ich denke dass das sowohl
von den Ukrainern wie auch von den von
den Russen gesehen wird dann gehen wir
ein Schritt weiter und bevor wir das tun
noch mal der Hinweis das sind Karten und
Grafiken und Informationen die Sie uns
vor der Sendung auch zur Verfügung
gestellt haben und zwar vom Zentrum für
Geoinformationen vielen Dank dafür und
jetzt noch mal der Blick weiter
mittig an der Frontlinie da haben wir
natürlich auch die weiteren Regionen ja
dieses ist also jetzt tatsächlich der
Bereich wo wie sie eben schon
angesprochen haben aktuell die Kämpfe
toben wenig Bewegung an der Front aber
Kämpfe in unfassbarer Härte die geprägt
sind
auf der geographischen Seite dadurch
dass es dort
erhebliche schlammprobleme gibt und zwar
auf beiden Seiten sowohl auf
ukrainischer Seite wie auch auf
russischer Seite ich denke wir alle
kennen die Bilder von ukrainischen
Soldaten in verschlampen schützen Gräben
vieles davon erinnert so ein bisschen an
den Ersten Weltkrieg an die
Schlachtfelder von Werder wo ähm Wälder
abgeholzt sind bis auf die Stümpfe wo
Ortschaften nicht mehr vorhanden sind
nur noch auf der Karte das ist dieser
mittlere Bereich der ist im Zuge der
Front dadurch charakterisiert das ist
die alte kontaktlinie mehr oder weniger
darstellt oder Teile der alten
kontaktlinie das heißt dort gibt es
gerade auf ukra unserer Seite mehrere
Linien tiefster und härtester
Verteidigungsstellungen und dahinter
gibt es allerdings
vergleichsweise offenes Land allerdings
auch dort immer wieder durchzogen von
einzelnen Flüssen die der mechanisierten
Führung der mechanisierten
Operationsführung erhebliche Grenzen
entgegengesetzt
entgegenstellen auf russischer Seite
befinden sich dorthin der stark
urbanisierte Gelände also verstädterte
Gebiete mit vielen Wohnungen und
Industriegebieten des Don Bass dafür
sehr bekannt insbesondere der Stadt
Donezk und auch das ist für eine
mechanisierte Krieg Führung eher
ungeeignet die Russen versuchen derzeit
was heißt derzeit eigentlich kann man
sagen seit mehr als über drei Monaten
hier mit massivsten Kräften unter fast
schon epischen Verlusten Durchbrüche zu
erzielen derzeit sieht es nicht danach
aus dass das Erfolg hat auch wenn sie
immer wieder kleinere taktische
Fortschritte haben zum zum Beispiel im
Bereich an DFK wie eben schon
angesprochen oder auch etwas weiter oben
bei bachmut das sind allerdings aktuell
nur taktische Fortschritte ob sich diese
auch in einen operativen Erfolg um
Münzen lassen ist derzeit fraglich ich
bezweifle das weil es dort hinter
weitere Verteidigungslinien der Ukrainer
gibt und dann natürlich wenn wir weiter
auf die Front schauen der Blick in den
Norden was zeigt sich da und was denken
sie da was gibt es dafür Informationen
was dort im Winter passieren wird
ja hier haben wir insbesondere die
Wichtigkeit des Frostes normal
hervorzuheben das heißt wenn der Frost
dann tatsächlich eintritt also
spätestens ab mitte ende diesen Monats
wird das der Fall sein im Januar dann
die von Ihnen genannten Minusgrade dann
wird der Boden hier Tiefgefrieren auch
dauerhaft das gilt für den mittleren
Bereich auch da hier eben violett
dargestellt und dann werden sich dort
für die mechanisierte Kriegsführung neue
Möglichkeiten ergeben bis zu einem
gewissen Grad das heißt man kann sagen
bis zu Temperaturen -10 Grad vielleicht
sogar -15 Grad spielt es dann der
mechanisierten Krieg Führung in die
Hände wenn es dann noch kälter wird dann
kommen die Härten des Winters zum tragen
sowohl für Menschen als auch für das
Gerät das heißt die Menschen müssen sich
dann warm halten es gibt Erfrierungen in
zunehmendem Maße beim Gerät wird es so
sein dass einzelne Geräte dann
festfrieren das der Diesel in den Tanks
ausflockt der Fahrzeuge das wird dann
also sehr unschön dann wird es wieder zu
einem Ruhezustand kommen allerdings
sehen wir aktuell bei den auf
ukrainischer Seite hier dargestellt auf
der Linie swatove kremina diese Linie
ist deshalb von Interesse weil auf
dieser Linie Verbindungsstraßen der
Russen laufen dass die Ukrainer
versuchen diese Verbindungsstraßen zu
unterbrechen es finden dort zurzeit
immer wieder Angriffe der Ukrainer Stadt
hier wird aktuell versucht auf
ukrainischer Seite die Schwächen der
Russen herauszufinden um dann wenn es
wirklich tiefgefroren ist und der Boden
für mechanisierte Operationen günstig
ist dann diese Erkenntnisse auszunutzen
und in die Tiefe bis zur Landesgrenze
vorzustoßen schwierig dabei ist dass
hier insbesondere bis zur Landesgrenze
immer wieder Flussläufe oder auch
Einschnitte da sind die quer zur
Angriffsrichtung verlaufen und damit
potenzielle
angriffsgeschwindigkeiten stark
reduzieren
verstehe also an Herausforderung aber
wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe
dann sehen sie dort schon für die
ukrainische Streitkraft eine Möglichkeit
bei den Frosttemperaturen dann auch
weiter vorzudringen und weitere
offensiven durchzuführen
also ich sehe
die größten Möglichkeiten für diejenige
Streit macht die am besten mit den
kalten Temperaturen klar kommt und nach
den mir vorliegenden Informationen sieht
es derzeit sehr stark danach aus dass
das die Ukrainer sind weil sie sich
lange darauf vorbereitet haben weil sie
durch den Westen auch von Deutschland
stark unterstützt sind wurden sind mit
Gerät für die für die
winterkriegsführung bei den Russen ist
das eher nicht der Fall die hatten über
das Jahr schon Probleme auch in den
günstigen Monaten überhaupt ihre Truppe
zu versorgen jetzt kommen noch mal die
neu ausgehobenen Reservisten hinzu die
mobics und wenn die Russen jetzt die
Anzahl der Kräfte erhöhen vielleicht
sogar verdoppeln an der Front dann
verdoppeln sich automatisch auch deren
logistische Probleme
auf die kommen wir gleich auch noch mal
zu sprechen die Einschätzung die sie
jetzt gerade geteilt haben ist doch eine
die von einem ukrainischen Geheimdienst
Experten gestützt wird dass es olexes
andre Kovalenko und er hat uns gestern
ein Interview gegeben und das wie gesagt
da hören wir jetzt mal zusammen rein
wurde im Winter wird es eine aktive
Offensive der Ukraine geben es liegt im
Interesse der Streitkräfte der Ukraine
ständig ein hohes Maß an
Feindseligkeiten aufrecht zu erhalten um
die russische Armee zu erschöpfen wenn
die aktive Offensive unterbrochen wird
kann Russland Ressourcen ansammeln und
die Offensivaktion wieder aufnehmen die
Ukraine ist gut auf die Winterperiode
vorbereitet in der Winterzeit fanden
viele groß angelegte Schlachten statt
ich fasse mal kurz zusammen sie sehen
anhand ihrer Informationen aktuell auch
die ukrainische Streitkraft besser und
adaptiver auf den Winter vorbereitet die
Informationen vom ukrainischen
Geheimdienstexperten die wir gerade
gehört haben ist dass er da schon eine
größere Offensive auch vermutet Herr
Schreiber um das einzuordnen es gibt
auch andere Einschätzungen zum Beispiel
Informationen des US-Geheimdienstes die
haben Mitte November prognostiziert dass
hier bis sozusagen jetzt auch bis der
Frost einstellt eigentlich nur noch Zeit
habe weiteres Gelände zu erobern und
dort ein Szenario dann auf kreiert eines
einer sogenannten kriegspause weil dann
eben die die Böden zu Schlamm werden
würden zu uns passierbaren wegen das
führen würde sehen Sie dieses Szenario
das diese Informationen zeigen dieses
kriegspausenszenario auch als
realistisch ein
das
kriegspausenszenario sehe ich als
unrealistisch an
aus zwei Gründen das eine ist
in dieser Region gibt es zwei
Jahreszeiten in denen man mechanisierte
Kriegführung betreiben kann das ist im
Winter und im Sommer im Frühjahr und im
Herbst findet dort nichts statt aufgrund
des Schlamms das haben wir im Frühjahr
gesehen die Russen sind
relativ schnell stecken geblieben und
das sehen wir jetzt auch wieder wo
eigentlich sämtliche größeren
Operationen im Schlamm stecken bleiben
und das zweite ist das ist eine ja mehr
oder weniger kann man sagen operative
ein operativer Grundsatz die
Entscheidung wird im Angriff gefunden
wird im Angriff gesucht und derjenige
der die Entscheidung haben will und ähm
beide Seiten wollen das aber für die
Ukraine ist es mehr oder weniger
lebenswichtig wird diesen Angriff
durchführen müssen wird das als
mechanisierte Operation durchführen
müssen und dafür ist eben nun mal
entweder der Winter der jetzt gerade vor
uns liegt oder der Sommer geeignet und
dieses Zeitfenster was ich gerade jetzt
öffnet ist das letzte Zeitfenster vor
dem beginnenden Sommer wo die Ukraine
noch mal erfolgreich Daumen greifen der
mechanisierte Operationen durchführen
kann
blicken wir auf die Taktik Moskau
zumindest das was sozusagen in der
Diskussion steht der generalsergesuche
wie kin der Kommandeur der Streitkräfte
der hat sich auch Mitte November
geäußert und er hat gemeint dass er
hoffe dass spricht dann wieder so ein
bisschen in dieses Szenario kriegspause
rein dass ich die Lage an der Front
beruhige in den Wintermonaten und auch
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens Stoltenberg
der hat heute davon gesprochen dass auch
eher Information darüber habe dass
Russland aber den Krieg nur kurz
einfrieren Wolle und dann auch im
Frühjahr selber wieder ausgeruht sein
und gegen offensiven Staaten zu können
deckt sich das mit ihren Informationen
eine Offensive im Frühjahr halte ich aus
den eben schon genannten Gründen für
ausgeschlossen oder nicht
erfolgversprechend egal von welcher
Seite sie kommen mag
die Russen versuchen derzeit Zeit zu
kaufen Zeit zu kaufen um größere Teile
der mobics auszubilden der Reservisten
um diese nach besten Wissen und Gewissen
zu kampfkräftigen Einheiten
zusammenzuführen dafür benötigen Sie
diese Zeit wenn in der operativen Krieg
Führung Zeit benötigt wird gibt es zwei
Währungen in Anführungszeichen mit dem
man diese Zeit kaufen kann das eine ist
durch die Aufgabe von Raum man gibt Raum
auf und gewinnt dadurch Zeit die Russen
können aus politischen Gründen keinen
Raum aufgeben denn das würde ja als
Niederlage bedeutet werden und dann gibt
es noch eine zweite Währung mit der man
mit der man Zeit kaufen kann und das ist
der gnadenlose Einsatz von Menschenleben
und ich glaube das ist das was wir
gerade auf russischer Seite sehen das
Teile der neu eingezogenen unmittelbar
an die Front geworfen werden als
Kanonenfutter muss man sagen um eben
diese Zeit zu kaufen für die anderen
Kräfte die dann sich in dieser Zeit
vorbereiten können um dann wenn es dann
wieder so weit ist von den
Witterungsbedingungen in die Offensive
gehen zu können
das ist auch etwas eine Einschätzung die
auch immer wieder hier in den
Kommentaren bei uns aufploppt wo wir
beim Thema sind ich leite ihn gerne
unsere erst user-frage weiter die kommt
von El Carado er fragt und bezieht sich
darüber noch mal auf die Orte Kriminal
und sehr wäre dann jetzt ähm fragt da
noch mal an sie würde da ein
vorschreiben und auch ein Durchbruch der
Ukraine in diesen Orten den Krieg
entscheidend verändern und beeinflussen
ob das den Krieg entscheidend verändern
oder beeinflussen wird ist natürlich
schwer vorauszusagen
unter den aktuellen Bedingungen
Stichwort Schlamm wahrscheinlich eher
nicht weil selbst wenn Einbruch erzielt
wird wird der vermutlich nicht
ausgenutzt werden können weil die
durchgebrochenen Kräfte kaum weiter in
die Tiefe vorstoßen können solange wie
diese Schlammperiode noch anhält und Sie
können auch nicht versorgt werden weil
die Logistik die diesen Truppen folgen
muss ebenfalls im Schlamm stecken
bleiben würde das heißt das wird
frühestens dann der Fall sein wenn der
Boden gefroren ist aber dieser Raum ist
aus meiner Sicht eigentlich eher weniger
geeignet um eine Kriegsentscheidung
herbeizuführen das trifft er auf den
Süden zu
eine Frage die sich direkt danach
anschließt die geht so ein bisschen
schon auf den Ausblick würde ich aber
trotzdem an der Stelle mal Vorziehen von
acefox der fragt sie Herr Schreiber was
ist da ihre Einschätzung werden wir den
Krieg im nächsten Jahr in Klammern
seiner Einschätzung wie auch immer
beendet haben oder glauben sie an
mehrere Jahre
ja die Länge des Krieges ist in dem
Falle wirklich eine Frage die uns
erstens natürlich alle bewegt die aber
unglaublich schwer zu
prognostizieren dass ich ich glaube dass
das alle Prognosen in diese Richtung
auch unseriös sind es gibt gewisse
Indikatoren anhand der man eine solche
Prognose natürlich
entlang aufbauen kann das ist zum
Beispiel die logistische
Durchhaltefähigkeit bei der
Kriegsparteien
aber ich glaube da wissen wir insgesamt
zu wenig für drüber insbesondere nicht
aus offenen Quellen wie weit die beiden
Kriegsparteien das noch durchhalten
können auf der konventionellen Ebene
also bottom line ich würde da keine
Prognose wagen
wie das dann wie lange das noch gehen
kann dann bleiben wir bei den
gesicherten Informationen sie haben das
Thema kriegslogistik angesprochen wir
haben gesprochen über die Frost
Entwicklung über die Veränderung der
Böden werden gesprochen über die
Taktiken die sich daraufhin im Winter
verändern können und die Korridore die
sich ergeben dann nehmen wir Punkt 3 die
kriegslogistik und die Transportwege wie
witzig das Verändern in Sachen
Transportwege für Nachschub für Munition
für Kleidung etc was sind da so
Informationen die sie haben
ja Logistik ist in diesem Krieg wie
eigentlich in jedem Krieg ein
entscheidender Faktor und je stärker
mechanisiert dieser Krieg geführt wird
und er wird auf beiden Seiten
schwermechanisiert geführt desto
wichtiger ist die Logistik
das russische System ist aufgebaut auf
einem depotsystem was
eisenbahntransporte bis an die Front
vorsieht und danach wird dort umgeladen
und in kurzen Wegen ähm bis an den an
die eigentliche Front versorgt jetzt
haben die Ukrainer mit westlichen
Artillerie Systemen Systeme zur
Verfügung die es Ihnen erlauben diese
Logistik extrem zu stören die Verteiler
Bahnhöfe zu zerstören was dazu führt
dass die Russen ihre Logistik weiter
nach hinten verlegen müssen das heißt
die Entladung der Eisenbahn muss
außerhalb der ukrainischen Artillerie
Schussweite erfolgen was automatisch die
Wege die dann mit dem LKW gemacht werden
müssen deutlich verlängert verdoppelt
teilweise sogar verdreifacht dann
brauchen Sie entweder die dreifache an
von LKW oder sie haben nur ein Drittel
der logistischen Leistung das ist ein
relativ einfaches Rechenexempel und das
trifft für die Ukraine in gleicher Weise
zu die Verbraucher in diesem Krieg sind
extrem hoch gerade Artillerie Munition
wir nennen das großverbrauchermunition
das sind Tonnagen über den gesamten
Frontverlauf im Bereich von mehreren
tausend bis hin zu 10.000 Tonnen
möglicherweise sogar am Tag die da
schnell mal durchgehen können und da
können sie sich in etwa vorstellen was
das bedeutet insbesondere wenn diese
Logistik durch Artillerie Feuer oder
eben auch durch das Wetter jetzt die
Periode gehemmt wird das heißt
das ist tatsächlich einen entscheidender
Faktoren wir haben festgestellt in
vergangenen Sommer dass die Ukrainer als
dann im Spätsommer die Offensive
losgegangen ist bis zu zwei
angriffsachsen parallel logistisch
versorgen können ich glaube mehr ist
auch nicht drin
die Russen können vermutlich aktuell nur
noch eine einzige Achse nämlich in der
Mitte also Don Bass zwischen donesk und
Lorentz logistisch unterstützen das wird
ausgesprochen schwierig für die Russen
und der Winter wird da ein Übriges dazu
tun
das Thema Winter und wie entscheiden das
den Krieg beeinflusst darüber sprechen
wir heute und ein entscheidender Punkt
ist dabei natürlich auch die Moral
sowohl bei den Soldaten als auch in der
Bevölkerung bisher wenn man den
Kriegsverlauf sich anschaut spricht ja
sehr vieles für die Moral der
ukrainischen Streitkräfte auf der einen
Seite und auch der Bevölkerung die jetzt
z.B auch gerade wieder den massiven
russischen Raketen Angriffen trotz die
zum Teil ja ganze Regionen und Städte
von der Wasser und Stromversorgung
abschneiden wie sehen sie da jetzt
sozusagen mit Blick auf den wirklich
bevorstehenden Winter auf das Abfallen
der Temperaturen wie sehen sie da die
Situation zwischen russischer Seite und
ukrainischer Seite in punkto Moral
ja was die Moral der beiden
Kriegsparteien betrifft hat sich glaube
ich wenig geändert die Ukrainer haben
eine hohe Moral sie haben gesehen dass
Sie erfolgreich sein können Sie wissen
dass ihr Land verteidigen nachdem jetzt
die Russen auch wahllos zivile
Infrastruktur angreifen eigentlich schon
den ganzen Krieg über ist den Ukraine
glaube ich auch vollständig klar worum
es in diesem Kredit nämlich um das
schlichte physische überleben und das
motiviert ungemein auf der russischen
Seite hat man immer wieder eigentlich
schon von Anbeginn an starke Zweifel
auch unter den Truppen feststellen
können worum es überhaupt geht in diesem
Krieg in dieser von Präsident Putin
ausgerufenen militärischen
spezialoperation keiner weiß was ist das
eigentliche Ziel viele sehen dass sie
schlecht versorgt werden dass es ein ein
riesen Problem im übrigen von daher die
Moral auf ukrainischer Seite deutlich
höher als auf russischer Seite
und ich glaube tatsächlich dass es sich
auf russischer Seite jetzt noch eher ins
Negative dreht weil jetzt mittlerweile
jede Menge Soldaten unter den
einberufenden sind die eigentlich wenig
Lust haben Krieg zu führen wer hat das
schon aber
die auch nicht wissen worum es geht die
schlecht geführt sind Führung ist ein
riesen Problem auf russischer Seite die
allein gelassen werden weil wir haben
viele Bilder gesehen dass das Truppe
einfach nur im Wald irgendwo abgekippt
wird sage ich einfach mal um sich dann
sie selbst überlassen worden ist das ist
natürlich nicht überall der Fall aber in
vielen Bereichen sowas hängt die Moral
ganz erheblich und dann kommt dazu dass
natürlich gerade bei den Russen jede
Menge
Soldaten dazu aufgefordert worden sind
ihr eigenes Material von zu Hause
mitzubringen das muss man sich mal vor
Augen führen was das eigentlich bedeutet
der Staat will diese Menschen haben und
sagt dann aber bringt euer eigenes Zeug
mit und ihr seid selbst dafür
verantwortlich das hebt die Moral nicht
unbedingt das
Material ist was Sie mitbringen ist
vielfach ungeeignet dann bleiben
Zahlungen aus dann bleiben die
versprochenen Zahlungen dann bleiben die
Hinterbliebenen Versorgungen aus dann
wissen die Familien nicht wo die
Soldaten sind all das trägt nicht zur
Erhöhung der Moral bei und wenn es jetzt
auch noch kalt wird dann wird gerade für
diese unterversorgte Truppe die Moral
möglicherweise zu einem richtigen
Problem wenn nicht sogar zu einem
Genickbruch und auch das Thema dann auch
Gesundheit im Winter ich meine da ist
man ja mehr gefährdet krank zu werden
als im Sommer man liest auch immer
wieder von zwei typischen Krankheiten
auch in einem Kriegsverlauf natürlich
die haben die Ausstattung angesprochen
Hautkrankheiten wenn Kleidung nicht mehr
gewaschen werden kann oder dem
sogenannten Schützengraben Fuß warum
sind das typische Krankheiten und wer
ist da wahrscheinlich eher von
Betroffenen im weiteren Verlauf
ja das sind typische Krankheiten die im
Grunde genommen bei Kälte und bei
mangelnder Hygiene entstehen und
entsprechend wird diejenige Truppe davon
weniger betroffen sein die sich erstens
besser gegen Kälte schützen kann zum
Beispiel durch
Öfen die sie mit in die Front bringen in
die Schützen Gräben aber auch
möglicherweise in ihre Unterkünfte die
etwas hinter der Front liegen
diejenige Truppe die häufiger so wie sie
es eben schon gesagt haben ihre Wäsche
auch mal wechseln kann und vor allem
auch diejenige Truppe die entsprechend
gut versorgt ist die entsprechend auch
was zu essen hat die Nahrungsmittel in
ausreichendem Umfang hat und die rotiert
wird das heißt dass die Truppe nicht
immer über Monate an derselben Stelle an
der Front ist sondern dass die
Truppenteile die an der Front sind
durchgetauscht werden um eben die Ruhe
und Regenerationsphasen einhalten zu
können denn wieder eben schon richtig
gesagt haben die ähm die Beanspruchung
von Mensch und Material hier reden wir
jetzt über den Menschen ist ganz
erheblich und ihr kennt das wird umso
umso relevanter wird wird dieses Thema
Blick noch mal in unsere Community da
kommt was rein von Donald Wollny bei
Youtube er fragt natürlich auch noch mal
mit Blick auf die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine aus dem Westen kann die Ukraine
das ist seine Frage mit Hilfe westlicher
Waffen mit Ausrüstung er spricht jetzt
hier zum Beispiel vom Leopard 1 Panzer
gerade im Winter die Frontlinie
durchbrechen ich glaube die Frage geht
ein bisschen in die Richtung wie
entscheidend auch die weiteren Hilfen
aus dem Westen sind für den Winter ja
ich denke da kann man ein ganz klares
Fazit ziehen
auch hier wieder ein militärischer
Grundsatz für die Entscheidung kann man
nie stark genug sein und ich denke es
ist gerade auf ukrainischer Seite klar
dass die Ukraine ohne
fortlaufende und permanente westliche
Hilfe
militärisch nicht überlebensfähig ist
und damit ist im Grunde genommen alles
gesagt ich glaube da geht es auch
weniger um um neue Waffensysteme da geht
es vor allen Dingen um die Versorgung
nicht nur mit mengenverbrauchsgütern
also Artilleriemunition im Speziellen
sondern auch mit Ersatzteilen
über die über die Monate und Wochen
hinweg weil die
Strapazierung die Strapazen des Geräts
ganz ganz erheblich sind da werden hohe
Feuerraten geschossen der Verschleiß ist
da und das muss ausgeglichen werden
ansonsten wird dieses Gerät über kurz
oder lang unbrauchbar
bei uns kommt ein Kommentar rein der auf
die Diskussion geht und das kommt von
Thomas Klein er sagt kein einziges Wort
gerade über Friedensverhandlungen machen
wir doch erschreiber sehen Sie das als
Möglichkeit in den nächsten Monaten und
Wochen im Winter
ja Friedensverhandlungen sind natürlich
immer ein politisches Thema weniger ein
militärisches Thema das heißt hier
geht's darum ist der politische Wille
für
Friedensverhandlungen da und wie sieht
dann die Kondition für diese
Friedensverhandlungen aus und nach allem
was ich bislang sehr auch von gerade von
russischer Seite glaube ich nicht dass
dieser Punkt an diesem an dieser Stelle
jetzt schon
erreicht ist
einfach
mangelsbereitschaft und ich glaube auch
dass die Ukraine da zurzeit eher wenig
dran interessiert sind weil sie
natürlich noch einige Ziele zu erreichen
haben diese sich vorgenommen haben und
die Präsident selenski ja auch klar
benannt hat nämlich die Rückeroberung
der von Russland 2014 annektierten
Gebiete einschließlich der Krim
entscheidender Punkt dafür wir haben
jetzt viel über die Situation am Boden
und auch der Wetterverhältnisse
gesprochen sind ja auch die Drohnen
Angriffe und erfolgreichen
Drohnenangriffe der Ukraine vom Montag
und auch von gestern da sehen wir noch
mal Bilder wie gesagt ausführlichen
Hintergrund Stream dazu findet Ihr bei
uns bei ZDF heute live könnt ihr euch
gerne anschauen das ist ein Thema was
Herr Schreiber die Community bei uns
auch noch beschäftigt z.B kommt eine
Frage von John Wayne er sagt unter den
Gegebenheiten werden jetzt wieder auf
der anderen Seite die Russen die nächste
Eskalationsstufe
versuchen einzuleiten und
auf ihrer Seite irgendwie noch mal mehr
völkerrechtswidrige Luftangriffe
durchzuführen wissen Sie darüber was
also darüber kann man glaube ich an
dieser Stelle nur spekulieren ich glaube
nicht dass die Russen
bislang muss man einfach sagen an
völkerrechtswidrigen Terrorangriffen
gespart haben sie werden das ohnehin
weitermachen und zwar unabhängig davon
ob die Ukraine jetzt irgendwelche
Flugplätze im russischen Hinterland
angreifen oder irgendwelche Depots die
Russen werden weitermachen sofern es in
ihren Möglichkeiten steht wenn Sie die
Möglichkeiten haben werden sie es machen
und wenn es eingestellt wird dann ist
das keine gut will Aktion der Russen
sondern dann ist es die zunehmende
Erschöpftheit der Vorräte Blick aber
vielleicht auch noch mal auf die andere
Seite auch eine Frage aus der Community
was sagt das aus dass die ukrainische
diese ukrainische Luftangriffe jetzt
auch so erfolgreich sind
also ich glaube der Erfolg der aktuellen
Angriffe der Ukrainer zeigt vor allem
auf die Schwäche der russischen
Flugabwehr denn das sind im Grunde
genommen Angriffe die mit den
umfänglichen Mitteln die die Russen
zumindest auf dem Papier zur Verfügung
haben abgewehrt hätten werden können und
hier scheint es das hat sich während des
gesamten Krieges im Grunde genommen
schon gezeigt dass gerade die die
russische Flugabwehr extreme Schwächen
hat die wir im Vorfeld des Krieges
eigentlich gar nicht zugetraut hätten
das Stichwort oder das Passwort heißt
hier in dem Falle Luft Raumordnung das
ist eine relativ komplexe Geschichte wo
im Grunde genommen die Flugabwehr mit
den eigenen Flugbewegungen
abgestimmt werden muss um nicht zu
friend die Feier so zu abschießen
eigener Flugzeuge durch die durch die
Flugabwehr zu führen und ich glaube das
ist dort massive Defizite bei den Russen
gibt das haben wir schon im eigentlich
wenn das gesamten Kriegsverlauf auch
gesehen und spätestens seit Sommer ist
es ist es virulent gerade auch im
Bereich Person hat man das gesehen die
Ukrainer konnten sich in der Luft frei
bewegen die Russen haben nur noch sehr
wenige Luftangriffe geflogen und wenn
sie Luft Angriffe fliegen dann werden
diese von den jetzt angegriffenen
fernbombern also von den
fernfliegerkräften durchgeführt die sich
weit außerhalb der Reichweite der
ukrainischen Flugabwehr befinden und
gleichzeitig sehen wir eben dass die
dass die Ukrainer immer wieder Erfolge
haben die russische Flugabwehr
überrumpeln wo sie es eigentlich gar
nicht sollen
detaillierte und tiefgründige
Informationen von Oberst in Generalstab
Andreas Schreiber vom German
institutec studies vielen Dank für Ihre
Zeit und für ihre Analysen mit Blick auf
den kommenden Kriegswinter danke ihnen
sehr sehr hoch
danke natürlich auch an euch fürs
zuschauen fürs Fragen stellen fürs
kommentieren fürs mitdiskutieren hat uns
sehr gefreut dass ihr bei uns gewesen
seid und schaltet gerne auch beim
nächsten Mal hier ZDF heute live ein
wenn wir uns sehr freuen bis dahin
macht's gut tschüss